Typically when we talk about
data transfer efficiency,
we're talking about limiting
the amount of data being transferred.
That reduces the
bandwidth and the cost
and is generally
a pretty good idea.
But on mobile there's an extra factor.
As you can see, it turns out
that the cell radio
is one of the biggest
battery drainers on the device.
So making your data
transfers more efficient
will also result in
improved battery life.
Now at a basic level,
being more efficient
means spending less time
transferring less data,
reducing your payloads,
and updating less often
can take you some of the way there.
But then what?
Can timing make a difference?
It turns out that it can,
and it's a situation
I like to think of as the
cookie Droid conundrum.
Do we perform fewer downloads
with larger payloads?
Or do we perform
lots of small transfers
just in time for when
we need them?
One big cookie or lots of little cookies?
So, what do you think?
Should we have a smaller
number of large downloads
illustrated by this big cookie?
Or a large number
of small downloads,
as illustrated by
lots of little cookies?